yeah hello and welcome to this  announcement for today's live shows on  its again a different time not different  to last week but it's not the usual one  we are starting at 4:30 in the afternoon  Central Europe in time for 90 minutes of  different splits that German show and  then find it then on 6 at 6 and evening  we have the English bendable show and  yeah these technical issues I hope I  have them resolved now I did a proper  dust cleaning of the notebook hands and  that really gained lots of yeah I gained  lots of fun too Thermal improvement  there so I should I think it should work  out now but yeah you never know until  you try it for three hours I hope you'll  manage to join it's basically a warm-up  for the scene filled cup and the links  are in the description thanks a lot for  watching